so obviously the question that I'm
teeing up right now is about the current
strikes that are happening right here on
this panel we are highlighting your work
as authors but writing screenplays is
just a step away and those guilds are
fighting for things that will not only
affect every single sector of the
entertainment industry and art but also
well beyond it as well so can each of
you maybe share your stance or
connection on these current strikes and
then also something in your own specific
profession as authors that would make
your jobs easier and would make the
experience of delivering your art more
fulfilling for you
um sorry big question I mean obviously
uh we support the guilds uh the wgas
Agatha I mean 100
um in uh I think writers should be paid
for their work I think everybody
creative should be paid
um fairly fairly compensated and I think
the creative arts you know Demands a
living wage I mean it is just
just so frightening how people are
devaluing what people do what workers do
and it is really scary
um and uh and I think we're at this
moment in time where you know people are
going to take a stand against it because
for the future you know for our kids you
know I mean I was always encouraged to
be an artist and a writer and to be
creative by my parents you know and I
encourage my kids to do that and I don't
want to tell her you know when you grow
up you can only be in Tech you know I
want her to feel like there's still a
thousand possibilities to be a creative
person in this world and it you know it
I was a journalist you know before I was
a writer and to see what happened to
print get decimated you know um and no
journalists anymore no magazines I mean
magazine editors are amazing creatures
you know who create these like wonderful
kind of fantasies that were so fun to to
have and you know like those are gone
you know and now you know and and I'm a
writer I'm author you know and seeing
what's happened to our industry to
publishing you know and then seeing you
know oh now it's happening to TV you
know now it's happening to film it's
it's just really like oh my God like we
we're not going to have nice things
anymore you know and it's just like it's
just really scary so you know it's going
to be an ugly fight it's already ugly I
mean they trim the trees really